today I want to make the case to you why
I believe 80% of college students Auto
dropout and I'm going to make a case why
it makes sense for them to drop out now
before you jump to conclusion with
anything I'm about to say my my
encouragement use watched the whole
thing because I have one purpose with
today's video
my purpose with today's video is not to
propose that education is a terrible
thing I've read over a thousand books in
my life as a self educated person and I
haven't had a four-year degree I'm a
college dropout myself it's not about
education isn't a good thing it's the
fact that I am NOT a fan of what's
happening with our current educational
system and I'm too concerned with the
fact that we are more like robots
following this and no one's questioning
it we're just kind of doing it through
through peer pressure and we're just
saying this is what we're supposed to do
so this is a video I would want you to
share if you're watching this and your
college students share with your parents
if you're watching this your parents
shared with your kids if you're watching
to share with the professor the Dean the
University I've spoken to so many
different universities of optics and
many times I get upset about it but it's
my strong opinions as an entrepreneur
why I believe in it's not before I get
into my points I'm going to talk about
who should drop out who should stay in
school why do we go to college what new
curriculums we ought to consider adding
to the school system the cost of books
on what it really cost them to make it
versus how much they sell our students
on how much the book cost I'm going to
talk about all that stuff but before I
get into a think about this here I think
when the biggest challenges we have
today is peer pressure and I'll explain
to you peer pressure a lot of times we
think college is what we have to do
because the kids have a peer pressure of
my friends getting accepted to UC
Berkeley or you know UT or FSU and and
Jacksonville or NYU so I gotta go also
because my friends going to college
forget about that peer pressure I'm
completely okay with that peer pressure
because kids got to compete and they
gotta learn about competition the peer
pressure that I do have a problem with
and I think no one is addressing is the
peer pressure of parents having to keep
up against other parents so it's almost
like a brother saying while my kid and
my sister's kids went to such and such
school I have to make sure my kids do
this because my kids have to do better
than my brother's kid or my sister kids
or my best friend's kids and all this
stuff and
I don't care how much it's going to cost
me to go into because they pay two
hundred thousand dollars honey will
refinance and take out a mortgage to pay
for our son school because we have to
say our son went to USC that family may
be making six hundred thousand dollars a
year this family can't afford to do
refinance because that's a retirement
money but through peer pressure they do
it just to keep up with their best
friend or their sister or their brother
and they pay for that college I have a
problem with that
and a last peer pressure that I believe
is is those who work in the educational
space you know those who are professors
teachers a Dean and you have to protect
your argument because sometimes you know
if you're single you have to make a case
why it makes sense to become single if
you're married you have to make a case
why everybody needs to be marry you ever
hear the story you know
married people recruit married people
single people recruit single people
divorced people recruit it doesn't
matter we recruit because we want to
make a case that we make the right
choice doing what we did that's totally
fine
sometimes educators are because you're
only in that world the only thing you
think is the most valuable thing is
education and that's really not the case
it's costing a lot of families a lot of
trials a lot of tribulations and I think
it needs to do address and I'm going to
make a case for it today and I'll be
almost like an attorney and I'll make my
case you be the judge you'll be the
juror and you can take all the shots you
want at me I will address all your
questions I post a question on my
website Patrick where David calm I got
tunnel tons of comments about this and
I'll read some of the people's comments
on the bottom as well at the end of the
video then I have a questionnaire that
I'm going to share with you for you to
take before you go to college I'll share
that with you at the end this one so let
me get right into it so first first
things first who in my opinion should
stay in school and continue school
because they need college 1 anybody who
is trying to become a professional
meaning a medical doctor dentist nurse
Arendt you need school and engineering
civil any kind of thing that's
engineering you need to go to school
lawyer you got to go to school you want
to go into politics all that said you
got to go into school to become a lawyer
and or if you're playing sports if
you're playing sports for school and
they've given you a full ride
scholarship you may as well take
advantage of it because you have a shot
at going to the next level I think you
definitely need to stay in school second
point
if yours if you're in school and want to
drop out but you're lazy I absolutely
don't recommend it I know a lot of kids
that say Pat I also want to drop out and
I want to stay in school Onalaska what's
the most you've ever worked in a week
well I just have a job I work 28 hours
in a week stay in school you still don't
know about work ethic because if you
don't know how to work harder you got to
be honest with yourself you got to stay
in school to learn discipline and hard
work if you at least know how to get a
degree maybe they'll teach you about
discipline and hard work 3 if you're in
school and you have a habit of not
finishing things stay in school at least
finish that thing if you have a habit of
not finishing things 4 if you're
accepted to an Ivy League school I think
it's a good idea to go to an Ivy League
school not everybody gets a chance to go
to Ivy League school if you go to Yale
Harvard any of those you ought to
continue there because that's a pretty
big deal to be accepted to some of those
schools 5 full ride scholarship and you
are fully clear about what you want to
do with your life
stay in school and I already cover the
sports part now who should drop out my
opinion one you got a strong work ethic
and you're not clear about what you're
doing drop out too if you're completely
undecided with your career path don't
waste your parents money see a lot of
times undecided kids rarely use their
own money undecided kids usually use
their parents money it's what they do
and if you're a parent I highly not
discourage you supporting an undecided
kid going to college because that's what
you're supposed to do think about it
this way imagine if your son or daughter
comes up to you and says mom I'm in love
I'm gonna propose a you know mom I'm
thinking about getting married ok
do you love this girl I think I love
this girl you think you loved I think I
love this grummy she's nice she's cool
we like both of us like the Raiders I
don't know why but we will both like the
Raiders kind of cool we like the same
things I think this will kind of work
out
mom were thing like getting married in
September and we're thing like getting
married at Hilton we did the numbers
it's going to cost about $70,000 can you
guys help us out what would you say to
that
if you said there's no way in the world
we would help pay for that wedding then
why are you paying for your kids going
to college when they're undecided what's
the difference it's an undecided
decision that you're funding why are we
funding an undecided decision that kid
needs to learn
and figure something out for life and
then come back to school
whoever said people have to go to school
from eighteen to twenty-two who came up
with that rule nobody did you can always
figure life out from eighteen to twenty
to go do some stuff and come back and go
to school 22 to 26 you got plenty of
time right but if it's undecided I don't
fund undecided things with my kids next
if you're great in sales and you have a
gift of gab and you have the hard work
again you're not clear about what you
want to do with college you can drop out
if you're disciplined you know you're
disciplined you work out you take care
of your body you're typically always
good about delivering and all that other
stuff when somebody says do this you
keep your word you're going to be okay
to drop out of school if you're
extremely competitive
absolutely competitive you're going to
make it you don't necessarily need to
have go to college if you have an easy
time making friends talking to strangers
people like to hire people like that who
know how to make friends or you're
charismatic charming all that stuff you
can drop out of college as long as you
have a strong work ethic or if you have
an opportunity to work on somebody
that's willing to mentor you they're
willing to coach you and know what
they're knowing themselves if someone's
willing to do that you will let me let
me put it in the simplest way possible
being mentored by somebody who is
absolutely established and successful is
worth more than getting an MBA from the
greatest school in the world let me say
one more time being mentored by somebody
who is absolutely successful and done
very well for themselves is worth more
than you go into the greatest school in
the world if that person is willing to
teach you what they know so that's who I
think oughta consider dropping out now
why drop out let's talk about why I drop
out so I talk about who should stay in
school who should drop out but why drop
out let's talk about that my problem
with school here's a problem that I have
with school I'm gonna give you first my
mathematical argument so watch the
numbers here okay in 1971 the average
house was worth twenty three thousand
nine hundred dollars let me say one more
time the average house in 1971 was worth
twenty-three thousand nine hundred
dollars today the average house is worth
two hundred and eighty-one thousand five
hundred dollars that means it's doubled
roughly twelve times pay attention to
the double number
so what a house was worth than 71 it's
double 12 times now our income in 1971
was ten thousand six hundred dollars in
1971 our income today according to the
Department of Labor is fifty three
thousand six fifty seven which means our
incomes doubled five times so our
incomes double five times but the cost
of a house has doubled
twelve times now stay with me here the
average cost of a four-year tuition to a
non-profit to a non-profit private
nonprofit university four-year average
cost per year was 1831 in 1971 matter of
fact Harvard was $2,600 I put all the
link to the information on the bottom
$2,600 but the average University was
1831 today in 2015 the average tuition
to a non-profit private school is thirty
one thousand two hundred thirty one
dollars that's seventeen times double is
what we're talking about seventeen times
it's double a public college was per
year was public four-year college was
five hundred dollars per year a public
today's ninety one thirty one thirty
nine that's an eighteen times double
that I'm giving you this is a CNBC
article with cost of living for college
so let me get this straight
tuition has doubled seventeen or
eighteen times cost of a house has
double twelve times our incomes double
five times and parents are still
pressured to pay for the school and of
their kids and use their own retirement
money and count on Social Security which
is probably not going to be able to be
activated at the age of sixty-five
because when they first came out with
Social Security and they came out with
age of 62 people were only living to 62
so they were not expecting people to
live so now parents have to use up their
money for kids college education and
retirement later on have to work for 75
80 years opens we're living longer and
you know we get stuck with that who do
you think has a support parents then
kids then have to support parents which
the ripple effect could cause kids to
get a divorce one parents do you want
your kids to get a divorce
and two kids do you want to take care of
your mommy and daddy for the rest of
your lives
that's a serious decision that's got to
be made on both parties now let me give
you another number here that bothers me
with college has become a business it's
become an epidemic right here's another
one average kid spends $1,200 in book
$1,200 even books some textbooks are
$200 a book I got I went and got a hold
it a most expensive book $200 contacting
my publisher I said how much would a
book like this cost if I wanted to make
five thousand of this copy of this book
they looked at it they came back they
said six dollars a book I said let me
get this straight
so this school gets the book it cost
some six dollars to make it and they
expect our kids and parents to pay $200
for this that's 33 times more on what it
costs to make money schools want to say
capitalism sucks I mean schools are
using a capitalistic system at a whole
different place
I understand wholesale and markup but
marking up from six dollars to two
hundred dollars that's embarrassing
Apple computers doesn't do that let
alone a college universities charging
that kind of money that's pathetic and
you ought to share this with other
people and the stats on these numbers
are also on the bottom that's also in
that same study done by done by CNBC
cost of books have gone up 82% 82% since
2002 that's three times the rate of
inflation if I could invest into college
books I would buy the stock college
books we'd become millionaires if we did
something like that that's what the cost
is I also believe colleges are producing
followers I don't believe they're
creating leaders it's a lot of just
somebody talks talks talk stuff yes yes
yes yes yes it's a lot of creating
followers I'm not saying everybody some
of you know and so I want to scroll it
up there's a lot of great professors out
there I'm not talking everybody but
generally the system isn't producing
what it's supposed to be producing and
it's costing way too much money to
produce the results that they're telling
us they're producing for it's become a
political game many universities it's
all about a recruiting to a political
injure that agenda that they have read
this book there's this and then they
recruit to a certain political party and
you got to kind of pay attention to that
as well five colleges have become a
business I don't know why we need to go
to college for four years
you know kids tell me so Pat do you
think if I'm majoring in business I
should go to school and get my four-year
degree I said I don't believe in four
years and I was even - Mark Cuban a
couple weeks ago and I asked him I said
what do you think about people who say
should drop out of college he says I
think they're idiots they don't know
what they're talking about I said why he
said because you should go to college
because you got a
accounting you got around these classes
I said so let me restate my question do
you believe college kids need to go to
college to get a four-year degree or do
they need to go to college if you take
these classes this know then you're
probably right they just need to take
these classes you can watch that take of
what he says in the interview Patrick
Brady with Mark Cuban will put the link
on the bottom you'll see that part when
he says that as well I don't think
somebody who's majoring in business
needs to take physics I don't think that
I think some of the mandatory classes
kids need to take to get a four-year
degrees or waste of time I would rather
have our educational system be change
and we rally behind it and instead of
requiring four years to get a bachelor's
degree in business why don't we make it
18 months you know instead of taking
four years I understand if you got to go
do surgery on my heart you need a lot of
years and watch and luck because a lot
of details I understand this is details
dentist I understand building the
structures a lot of details that's yours
you're not going to learn it in six 12
18 months I get that but business for
years what for what for it just makes no
sense to me right what a lot of these
courses that we take I'm not a fan of
both parents and students getting into
major that think about it whether the
parent pays for it it's going to take
them years to pay or they're going to
take years away from retirement if the
kids got to take pay for it it could
take them 20 years to pay for it we deal
with student loans and I see how many
kids and how many marriages are just
stuck paying $1,500 a month $1,100 a
month
nine hundred dollars a month of their
college loan that affects the marriage
that affects buying a house that affects
a lot of other things just because they
were told you got to go get a four-year
degree no what's the weirdest things
about most people that I say would that
have degrees their jobs generally has
nothing to do with their degree I hire
people left and right with my company we
have 2,000 agents roughly that work for
our firm in 30 something states most
people that have a degree their current
job has nothing to do with the degree
they got nothing to do with the degree
they got so now let me continue someone
will say here Patrick I don't care what
you say
I'm a parent and I'm gonna pay for my
kids school and no matter what because
we have a tradition in our family
everybody went to USC everybody wants
University of Texas we're all alumni so
Texas saying and we're all alumni the
Florida stay we're all alumni of NYU I
totally get it totally fine how much
money did you make last year well we do
well we make a summer around a million
dollars ma'am you make a million dollars
you can afford to risk $200 with $20,000
of kids going to school is that really
going to affect your retirement no not
really we're set forever an average
family making 150 or 200 thousand
dollars over four year period asks a lot
of money so this message isn't for the
people that are making a millionaire and
up we can afford that I'm talking
general families who are sacrificing
every single thing to give everything
they got for their kids and the kid goes
to school and is undecided and either
drops out and they're still responsible
for that bit and they're stuck with that
savings that's that's the problem that I
have with uh with any of that stuff now
let me get into the next part here why
are we going to college in the first
place so parents say well I want my kids
to go to college or kids say I want to
go to college I want to want to go to
college well I don't want my kids to
miss out on the on the fun partying side
of life and college and fraternity and
all this other stuff I don't really
think you need to go to college to party
you don't need a degree to learn how to
party quite frankly I went to the army
and then my army stories of partying
every time I talk to other kids who went
to school and they tell me they're crazy
partying it's not even close to the way
we partied in the arm it's just not in
this so if you want your kids to really
party
send them to the military they'll really
learn how to party when they're in
uniform and how people look at them and
uniforms sure your son's going to really
appreciate it if you send them to the
army so the fun part it doesn't require
a lot of discipline to party Thursday
night is lady nice for anybody
Thursday night ladies night that's
pretty much in every single state in
America kids are going to find a way to
party from eighteen to twenty five
that's just going to happen to well I
want them to get the experience what
experience quite frankly I have a
challenge with one thing with college my
challenge with college is were being
taught someone on business that's never
run a business before
why would somebody teach business that's
never ran a business before
why would somebody teach some things
that they've never done before why would
we want our kids to learn what if the
setup was a complete different way of a
setup
well then maybe that makes sense and
I'll talk about that a little later on
in the subject that I think we ought to
teach you know I want my kids to go to
college because they get to networking
college really yeah I think they get to
networking college and meet other people
networking and meeting other people is
not because of college
it's because your kid is good at doing
that I promise your persons not good at
networking they're not going to be good
at networking if we put them in the
military who put them in college if we
put them anywhere they're just not going
to be good at networking now if you
think they're going to get better at
networking because they're going to
drink beer and loosen up well that's a
different story
anybody can loosen up by drinking a beer
and networking better I'm talking purely
to network networking is something good
persons are good at doing I was in a
military that was soldiers that never
spoke to anybody and I was in a military
there were people that talked to
everybody same goes with college to get
a good job nowadays quite frankly with
the amount of inventory of people that
have degrees on career builder or
monster or any of that stuff I don't
think we're lacking the amount of people
with degrees that are unemployed for an
employer to hire I don't think we're
lacking that so your kid getting a
degree or you getting a degree if you
think that's going to give you an edge
on everybody else as a CEO myself I
don't even look at the degree that you
have from school I simply sit and ask
Tim your life experiences what trials
have you gone through what challenges
have you faced what have you overcome
what are some of your biggest victories
in life what languages do you speak what
countries have you been to what's the
hardest thing you have over that's what
I want to know I don't even look at your
degree that you get I don't I look at
those types of things when I'm hiring
somebody and I am a CEO myself as a
running a company we look at that
another one is my parents said so you
know my parents said so is something
that you know as much as we try to sit
there and talk about that whole thing I
talked about parents peer pressure
earlier sometimes parents peer pressure
it's a video definitely I suggest
parents to watch understand parents
please send messages if you disagree
with this please but all I'm asking for
is for people who are watching this talk
about this debate this break this
argument down at the dinner table say I
want to talk about a video I watch do
you agree with it I totally disagree
with the guy and break it down we're
going to come up with good resolutions
if we talk about these things somebody
says why are you going to college I'm
clear on my career perfect I support it
you ought to continue going to college I
want to figure out what I want to do
absolutely not
drop out you're not spending mommy's
money or your money
trying to figure something out in
college and I would suggest kids listen
I partied hard core of my life I partied
a lot I had a lot of fun with my life
and I just didn't want to waste my
parents money because my parents
sacrificed everything they had to come
to America and when we were living in
Iran as a Christian family living in
Iran it was very difficult the Moho
mania at six weeks later we escaped we
went to a refugee camp in Germany and
from Germany we came to the States here
and they got a divorce it was very
difficult for them and then I served the
military the last thing I wanted to ask
my parents for money I don't want to ask
my parents for money because I wanted to
kind of prove to them that I can survive
on my own so I knew when I was partying
hard I don't want them to pay for my
partying and if you're somebody that's
doing that man up and woman up and go to
your parents and tell them and say mom
dad I think you guys are wasting your
money putting me through college here's
why I'm just not disciplined be honest
with them you have no idea how much
respect you'll gain from them by doing
that so with that being said with that
being said now my opinion what we ought
to do before dropping out of college so
someone says you know what Pat I get
messages that I so agree with you this
is why I'm dropping out of college
you're absolutely right wait wait wait
before you drop out of college I have
some points before you drop out of
college one you've got to have a source
of income you gotta have a source of
income before you drop out of college
it's not just they joined this you know
exciting new thing I'm gonna drop out of
college I don't want any
responsibilities this message has
nothing to do with responsibilities my
behind me says read I've read over a
thousand books so don't think this is
like khumba I'm joining this club of
dropping out of college gonna go be a
billionaire Zuckerberg dinkum didn't
become a billion because he wanted to
drop out of college because he didn't
want responsibilities he dropped out of
college and work 120 hours a week is
what he did big difference remember this
jobs work this butt off so all these
entrepreneur heroes that people have
behind closed doors before they became a
hero they worked very hard so before
dropping out you gotta have a source of
income to learn sales yo no sales learn
sales if you kind of want to get
discipline you don't have a lot of
discipline I highly highly endorse
military Air Force would be my first
choice because they're all about
education coming out of Air Force then
it would probably be Navy army Marines
and no unless and I'm arming I'm putting
you three because I just think they got
to focus a little bit more on education
and I don't necessarily think army and
in spends as much time on education as
they ought to airforce definitely does
it's a great experience they treat you
like you know they treat your royal in
Air Force you almost look like you're
living in a hotel they change your bed
it's very different I mean an army life
living in a barracks and Marines anyways
the lifestyles getting better regardless
the other day I went to 101st Airborne
Division the unit I was at I didn't
recognize it because they don't look
like barracks it looked like a Holiday
Inn Hotel it's a complete different life
they're providing for military
servicemen many CEOs many CEOs many
politicians many presidents served in a
military before it teaches a lot about
independence and discipline travel the
world I'm a big fan of travel in the
world that can't see tell people go see
the world you know if you are undecided
and you have work ethic get a backpack
partner with somebody don't go by
yourself go experience what it is to
live in Europe go experience what it is
to live in Brazil go experience what it
is to live in Canada live in UK go work
for a different learn the culture learn
the community have that experience when
somebody sits in front of me I'm
interviewing and they tell me I live the
yeren UK I live the yeren Spain I'm
fascinated by it I know how to speak
Spanish I went on a mission I am
fascinated by it and I like that because
in a way that person may not be 48 years
old but that person has more of a
worldly experience than a 48 year old
who's never been out of the country
that to me has a lot of value than a
four-year degree I put it there I put it
there because I think there's a lot of
value to it work under CEO for free and
listen to everything he tells you work
under a CEO for free whatever she tells
you or he tells you listen learn learn
from them okay work for an entrepreneur
for free while having a source of income
because you can always do the college
thing from 22 to 26 I think sometimes
the challenge that we have is we put all
kids in one box it's just one system
everybody has to follow think about if
we have four kids you and I have four
kids together okay or you and your wife
or you and your husband have four kids
one of your kids every time you watch
your kid this kid will watch a patent
movie over and over and over again
he watches 300 over Nick he wants his
Braveheart Patriot Saving Private Ryan
you know he's always uniform all this
stuff maybe your kid wants to join the
military
let him
watch what they want to do and develop
their strengths and their calling not
because you went to school let the kids
see maybe militaries around you watch a
kinako this kid is just all about you
know friendly with everybody he goes and
networks with everybody he goes and
shakes hands with everybody is so good
smile charm all this stuff maybe he's an
entrepreneur you know ye you know
entrepreneur maybe you got a kid that's
always like arguing with you constantly
debating with you maybe that's kids an
attorney maybe that kid nice also could
be an entrepreneur run a business
because he's going to make them good
negotiator right maybe got a kid that's
always curious about health and how are
you how you doin mom are you feeling
that maybe that's a doctor I got nursing
maybe there's a connection but pay
attention and don't put them in the box
thinking every kid is going to be the
same if a kid loves politics if you got
a kid at four years old six years old
enjoy listening to Sean Hannity Bill
O'Reilly or Anderson Cooper or Rachel
Maddow and you're like what is this kid
doing listen maybe there are like
politics maybe it's college to pursue
politics in the future but not everyone
fits the same mold on what they need to
be doing now this is the subjects that I
would be teaching if I was running the
university today and I think we need to
be teaching the subject it was a song
that I saw recently somebody shared with
me I'll put the link of the song on the
bottom videos got six and a half million
views a kid talks about drop out of
school and stay in school something like
that let's put the link on the bottom
that they can see it as well Paul is
what we'll do you can see he made a lot
of good arguments on what you need to be
worried about but life but if I'm
running the school and I have a
university I want to see what are the
biggest problems were facing in the
world right now
and I want to teach that for instance
marriage two out of three marriages in
America and about a divorce how about we
talk about it how about we explain
listen here's marriage let's talk about
marriage why do we even get married in
the first place what's the purpose of
marriage is just tax purposes is it to
have kids is it because what I would
process marriage and I would talk about
bringing people who have been married
for thirty years have a successful
personal life have raised good kids
and I would have three a panel of three
parents where it's a six-hour panel and
kids talk to them
and they're talking about marriage what
works problems maybe issues they went
through that they're willing to be
vulnerable and share with the kids kids
are going to remember that they're
adults at that time 18 19 20 years old
we need to talk about marriage we need
to talk about those types of things
in universities in colleges I would send
my kids to your school if that was the
case if you're going to teach those type
of things and there's a panel to it not
just somebody getting up and talking
about how to have a good marriage and
they've never been married before we
have too many experts nowadays how their
time' what they've done you know here's
what you need to be have a successful
marriage they've been divorced 17 times
no I want somebody that's going to talk
about marriage that's been married 30
years I want a personal trainer that's
in shape I want an entrepreneur giving
me advice that's actually running a
business I want somebody who knows what
they're doing right - I'll have somebody
get up there talking about taxes how to
position yourself to pay the lowest
amount of taxes how to position your set
to pay the highest amount of taxes how
benefits of having your own business if
you have your own business you get tax
write-offs and you can do this and I
would get details about positioning
yourself for taxes I would talk about
that because you need to educate kids
come out of oh my gosh I'm paying taxes
what is this all about then they're
confused we need to teach that three
money I spent a lot of time talking
about money and I'm not talking about
economics class here's a stock a stock
is a certificate of ownership CD is a
certificate of departmental specific
specific here's short-term plan midterm
plan long term plan here's a mutual fund
here's why in annuity make sense here's
an insurance policy here's my any life
insurance he has here's how good 401k
this is why if a company doesn't offer
this look for this if a company's
offering that look for that they're not
matching do this specifics to the tee
and I would bring people who are money
managers to explain what would you do if
you were 19 20 years old to make sure by
45 years old you're set financially or
55 years old and I would have three
experts with three different
philosophies teaching not the professor
professionals is who would be teaching
to them in the subject of finance
another thing I've been teaching I'll be
teaching kids how to vote you know a lot
of kids don't know how to vote they're
just kind of sitting there saying well
do I would Republican Democrat this you
know am i a Democrat because my family's
a Democrat my father's a Republican what
do I do I don't know
what to do so I would have I would have
a Republican a Democrat and an
independent cup put them up there pick
the top 20 most important issues that
they debate and pose the questions with
no interference from the professor
let them debate for three hours let them
go at it and we're learning and you're
processing and saying that guy's
argument makes sense this why is that
guy getting nervous why is he bickering
maybe there's a reason let me ask him
another question they're going to learn
more about their own political beliefs
when they see the debate taking place
and I would do this three different
times with different personalities so
it's not the strongest Democrat ones or
the strongest Republicans wins I would
get different personality somebody wants
each time a different personality and
then they're going to be able to assess
which one makes sense to them I would
have a chapel Asst a communist and a
socialist debate in front of the kids
I would pay $100,000 a year for my kids
to go to that school the other thing I
would do is religion a lot of times
professors will lean towards atheism or
agnostic or certain religion and they
will impose that on their kids and
they'll mock maybe someone who believes
in God or vice versa somebody who
doesn't believe in God regardless I
would have an atheist a Christian or
Catholic or Mormon a Jehovah a Muslim it
doesn't matter
debate and maybe the kid at the ends
going to come out of so everybody say
the same thing maybe it's going to come
out of said wait a minute
it sounds like everyone agrees so let me
ask you a question what do you guys in
film about this what do you guys think
about this what do you guys say there's
a lot so what is who is the real truth
why is your religion to truth what then
they're going to be able to make an
assessment for themselves parenting we
have problems with parenting why don't
we start teaching kids how to parent as
adults young adults at 18 19 years old
yes teaching them how to raise kids
teaching them how to discipline kids not
by professors teaching them by a person
who has raised great kids been married
for thirty years
raise great kids teach them and give
examples and then bring the kids that
have done very well and they talk about
how their parents raise them so maybe
have the kids there and have the parents
there and kids are asking questions
these 18 19 20 21 22 year-olds are
asking questions hey how about this how
about when you go through this how about
when you go through here's what we do my
dad did this what happened when you got
a bad girl what did your dad do what
happened let them learn and then these
parents are also going to say don't
expect to go back home and saying your
parents are not
perfect call your mom and dad and say
hey your mom sucks your mom that has no
cloud apparent that no they're also
going to say don't expect perfection
from your parents so you can also sit
down the kids going to say you know what
I've been so hard on my mom and dad man
I need to call them tell my mom how much
I love her yeah I need to call my dad in
time and then it's also I'm going to
learn how to pair my kiss like this I'm
going to do this they're going to pick
up these are life decisions people make
divorces they fall bankruptcies they
have tax liens they get audited they
take they get they get into heated
heated debates and battles and arguments
over politics they get into major
arguments over religion they lose the
relationship with their kids because
nobody is teaching this stuff when we're
in college in school why not
universities why not professors now you
may say we teach it on my school why not
raise the standards and teach it at all
schools how come this is not part of
curriculum I said we add it to the
curriculum that's what I'm saying to add
it to the curriculum if you want my
three and a half year old on two year
old right now I got one in the oven
right now if you want me as a parent to
say yeah I'm going to send my kids to
schools why don't we do something about
that curriculum now so by then we're
endorsing kids going to school can maybe
we need we are going to send our kids to
school for four years because you're
teaching this stuff because you're doing
these things that we need to be doing so
that's my opinion on what I think my
college they're very strong opinions I
don't expect you to fully agree with
everything I may be wrong with every one
of the things I should I could
absolutely be wrong with everything I
shared with you here today and I'm okay
with that all I'm saying is let's open
the discussion and start talking about
these types of things now I want to
share a couple comments ago when I got
the wrote the question and I said why
should somebody drop out or stay in
school
I got a few different stories I'll share
three of them with you very quickly
first one is Douglas Dale was a managing
partner in Arizona somewhere and he come
he came back and he said this when it
comes down to it I'm a recent graduate
with two degrees one in business or one
in communication while I would agree
that any and all of skills I learned
could have been obtained in real world
there is - quite a bit that couldn't
learn that I did in education more
employers look for degrees to create a
benchmark within their businesses while
others look for experience when it comes
on to society we are all on unlevel
playing field either you have a degree
or experience but neither is more
correct than the other
really depends on the career choice you
make as the individual I was raised on
education and told that at my bank I
need to get a degree I am now in process
of getting my dual MBAs because I see it
as a good route for me and my career
good for you Douglas and a great
argument here's Pablo from Spain he's a
first officer at Norwegian Air Show he
said I have a college degree but I
really think that it was not really
useful and didn't prepare me for what I
went through under in the real world I
have learned everything with experience
but I think College give you some skill
that could help you later on in life
Thank You Pablo from Spain here's a toca
Sony malohkeh from South Africa okay he
said I'm a dropout not because I wanted
but I didn't have enough money to fund
my education I was only left with two
subjects to complete my degree this has
been a blessing in disguise because
since I left school I was placed the
value hard work above all less this has
brought me closer to many opportunities
I was always I always have to work hard
because I'm not a graduate regardless of
how much I know being a drop that also
helped me understand that the real world
owes me nothing good for you with that
type of a mindset here's the last one
I'll be - Antonio Rubio said he works in
Lima Peru hello Patrick colors an
important and beautiful stage but if you
only plan if you only plan to rely on a
degree this is very evil today the
people live in the safety of the house
then move to safety of the college then
move to safety of a company and the
problem is that there people don't live
and don't take experience in the real
world don't expand the context and
realities don't achieve their full
potential they are safe how we're in
college you have the opportunity to make
friends build relation for the future
learn to read and create the habit a bit
more but the principle problem that I
see in college the fact that we are
evaluated on independent ratings and we
tend to be alone and not cooperate with
a group interesting in the real world to
grow and to succeed we need to cooperate
and work with them as a team and you
know what the college is good good and
important thing and it's only my opinion
but the system is old it would be good
for students that they choose their
courses and make the perfect / make the
perfect career for themselves and
evaluate the rating by groups create the
system and a challenge is a challenge
but it is a better for the future so I
pass the ball on colleges and invite
them to take up the challenge and making
of making a modern valuation plan Wow
Thank You Antonio from Lima Peru very
very impressed with your comments bye
everybody
I welcome you to comment I welcome you
to debate I welcome you to share this
video with college students with high
school kids with parents with anybody
who's an educator you are involved in
that world and even any politicians that
you know to hear this concept out and
start talking about it all around the
world this is not something that's just
an American thing this is a worldly
think that we need to improve and start
talking about things that really really
matter so here's my challenge to you if
you're somebody that's thinking about
going to college you're currently in
college or your parent go to my website
Patrick baby be calm I have a
questionnaire prepared for you two
assets called stay in school or drop out
test stay in school or drop out test and
it's a questionnaire to go through and
you get a score at the end and based on
that score it'll tell you to either stay
in school or drop out and once you take
the test I encourage you to share with
other people and have other people take
the test and share this video with them
as well again if you have any questions
comment on the bottom I will definitely
be getting back to personally when I
have a chance to thanks for watching